An attorney
for former
President Trump blames
the media for Trump's claim
that he'll be arrested on Tuesday
in Manhattan.
In a statement to CNN, Joe Tacopina says
No one tells us anything,
which is very frustrating.
President Trump is basing his response
on press reports
and the fact
that this is a political prosecution
and the D.A.
leaks things to the press
instead of communicating to the lawyers,
as they should.
Now, this drama began
earlier today
on Trump's truth, a social page
after predicting his arrest on Tuesday.
The former president urged his supporters
to, quote, take back our nation.
And tonight,
his campaign is already fundraise
off of his claims,
which have not been confirmed.
There's no indication
that he will be arrested Tuesday.
Now, sources
tell me and my colleague Kristen Holmes
that Trump's legal team has gotten
no word from the Manhattan
district attorney's office
about the timing
of any possible indictment.
Another source says the former president
has been pushing his team
to get the base riled up over the idea
because he believes
it would help him politically.
CNN's Caitlin
Polanco is following
the latest developments
in this long time investigation
into possible hush money payments.
Paula, Donald Trump
does say
that he is expecting
to be arrested
on Tuesday
in Manhattan in this ongoing
financial crimes investigation,
but he actually doesn't
know at this point in time.
A spokesperson for Trump
said this morning in a statement
that there has been
no indication formally
from the Manhattan
district attorney's office
that Trump is about to be indicted
or arrested.
However, we do know that
this ongoing investigation into possible
financial crimes
may be falsification of business
records of the Trump Organization,
all connecting
back to that $130,000 payment
that Trump's lawyer, Michael Cohen,
made to Stormy Daniels to cover up things
that she wanted
to allege in his 2016 campaign.
All of that investigation
is nearing the end
because Trump was invited to testify,
which he had the right to do.
He declined to do that.
That is the sort of thing
that happens at the very end
of a grand jury investigation like this.
But we do know
that there is another witness
coming into the grand jury on Monday.
At least scheduled to be testifying.
And so at this point in time,
we don't know exactly when
or exactly
what charges may be approved
or may be asked to be approved
by the grand jury
sitting in Manhattan
in this unprecedented investigation
that could lead to a criminal charge
against the former president
of the United States Paula.
Caitlin, Paul, Lance, thank you.
Meantime, sources
tell CNN that meetings have been going on
throughout the week
among city,
state and federal law enforcement
agencies in New York
about security preparations
in case Trump's predictions are correct.
CNN's Polo Sandoval is outside
the Manhattan
Criminal Courthouse with more.
Polo, CNN has learned
that NYPD officials were briefed
on security measures today
Yeah, Polo,
these law enforcement officials
that are engaged in these
ongoing behind the scenes
conversations telling CNN
that there are some concerns
that they've raised.
When should or at least
should we reach that point
where Donald Trump
would have to come here
to lower Manhattan
to answer to any potential charges?
And among those concerns
would certainly be courthouse security.
A reminder,
we do live in a post January 6th World.
And so
there are certainly concerns
about the potential for demonstrations
or rallies
by Trump supporters
and that today's message
from the former president
could further galvanize them
to take them beyond just peaceful protest
and then resulting
counterprotest, perhaps.
And that is why local, state
and federal officials,
according to several sources
speaking to CNN,
are having these conversations
about how they would respond.
Another just fascinating
wrinkle in all of this,
Paula, is
what one federal source
told our colleague, John Miller,
that the former president's
Secret Service
protective detail
is also engaged in conversations
with fellow agents here in New York City
about what the logistics would look like
in terms of transporting Donald Trump
to the region
here, to the Manhattan
district attorney's office to respond
or at least
to face any potential charges
and go through the booking process
just like any other way,
which would include
fingerprinting, mug shot
photos being taken and, of course
the eventual eventual arraignment
of a defendant,
obviously
because of the attention on this.
It is expected that this would be
this would happen away
from crowds, away from cameras.
But we'll certainly have to see,
of course,
should we arrive at that point.
But it just goes to speak
to the fascinating and unprecedented
nature of the behind
the scenes conversations
that are happening among
those are obviously coming from
law enforcement
that are
trying to sort of forecast
where we would be
should we reach that point.
Of course,
we're talking about charges being filed
against the former president Paula.
Polo Sandoval, thank you
And joining
us now,
CNN national security analyst
Juliette Kayyem.
She's also a former assistant secretary
at the Department of Homeland Security.
Juliette, of course,
calling for protests is legal,
protected by the First Amendment.
But how much does
the specter of January six
hang over
Trump's latest
remarks calling for protest,
protest protests?
Right.
Even before January six,
Trump became an expert
or was an expert
in using language
to incite without actually directing it.
I mean, even for January six,
it was clear what he wanted to happen.
But he never said,
you know, storm Congress and and lose.
And I think
actually the language in his statement
this morning,
what was less troublesome is protest.
That's fine.
Where democracy was his
take America back language.
That's directly from January six.
But the language that he used on
January six, somehow
something's being taken away from me.
And I have to fight
essentially with violence to get it back.
But the the times have changed
and and Trump will begin to realize that.
I mean, one is he's not in power.
So we can't direct
law enforcement agencies.
Hundreds of people are in jail
or been indicted.
He he cannot promise to pardon people.
Law enforcement, as we're reporting,
is clearly on notice.
And and he's thrown out this Tuesday day.
I kind of doubt it.
I don't know
if they're
honestly following their interviewing
a witness on Monday.
The Tuesday date is probably Trump
wanting to have us all look at Tuesday.
It doesn't happen.
And him saying look, they don't have it.
So we just wait
until there's actually movement.
You make a great point.
And again,
our reporting is
there is no indication
that there is an arrest on Tuesday.
His team hasn't been told that.
And as we've been reporting,
there's a witness coming Monday.
But as Trump calls
for the protests,
the House speaker, Kevin McCarthy,
he's got on Twitter to say
any arrest
would be, quote,
an outrageous
abuse of power by a radical D.A.
who lets violent criminals walk
as he pursues political vengeance
against President Trump.
Now, how do those remarks play?
Because really, he's
talking about
the potentially politically
motivated prosecution.
But Trump is calling for people
to take back the country to the streets
Yeah. Yeah.
You can't reconcile with that, really.
Right.
And I found McCarthy McCarthy's statement
pretty weak.
I mean, I know people get upset by them,
but so you're going to have a hearing.
Like what aren't
they having a hearing about, actually?
I mean, look,
I found a week
I sort of viewed it as performative,
like he sort of has to do this.
But if you're Trump
and the speaker of the House
in your party
is not saying
what you would
probably want him to say,
which is not just that it's outrageous,
but people should protest and
protect Trump.
You're going to be a little bit nervous.
And I think that's
I think it's
I think we we sometimes look at the smoke
and all the people yelling
and Fox News and think,
oh, you know,
obviously Trump is still popular,
but everyone's
going to take to the streets.
And even worse,
some of them will take to arms.
And I think if you just sort of look back
since January six,
there's tremendous amount of evidence
as well
that that that was the peak
and that he's just not able
essentially to fill a room.
Look at C-PAC
when you've got you
what we were
reporting on CPAC last weekend.
He can't fill a room
where people pay to see him. So.
So I'm you know,
I mean,
I think that
McCarthy's statement,
again, was performative.
Well,
let's talk about the security concerns.
If there is an indictment,
if he does go in person
for his initial appearance
as someone who's worked
at the Department of Homeland Security.
Yeah.
What kind of things are you looking at?
Because that courthouse on an average day
is a circus with high profile defendants,
as I'm sure you know.
There is paparazzi,
there's foreign press.
It can be quite quite chaotic.
What are they looking at
with the idea
of a former president
possibly showing up there
for an arraignment?
Right.
So there's all the different pieces
are going to happen.
In different locations as well.
So first, I just,
you know,
follow the threat
stream, the intelligence stream.
We don't know if other things
might happen in other cities as well.
So first,
this is the Secret Service,
which is put in in a historic position,
which is
they would have to deliver the body
of the president essentially
to a new courthouse so
and there's always been speculation
about the extent to which in the past
that group of presidential detailees
had been sort of
taken with Trump
that has changed over time.
And I suspect that there is
there is a lot of focus on
who the personnel will be
over in New York.
You're going to have a control,
geographic control of the courtroom.
I do not mean to make this analogy.
It's just a helpful one.
This courthouse knows
how to prepare for defendants.
It was preparing
for Guantanamo defendants.
It has had high
profile terrorism defendants
Trump is not one of them.
This is a different kind of case.
It knows how to do this
with with the NYPD.
They know how to control
the the area around it
and then also those who
who legitimately have access to it.
My biggest concern is,
of course, for the people
who are prosecuting this case,
they will have increased
security details as well.
They are more vulnerable
because they're just
human beings doing their job
and they have families
and things like that.
So those are sort of the three areas
that the security will be looking at.
And we'll see if there
actually is an indictment and if it comes
this week.
Juliette Kayyem, thank you so much.